[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen schönen guten abend ihnen
allen und wieder bei mir für den sport
ist kristin otto vorfreude guten abend
dann blicken wir gemeinsam auf unserer
heutigen themen
bangen vor dem jahrestag die ukraine
fürchtet dass russland 77 jahre nach
ende des zweiten weltkriegs seine
angriffe ab morgen ausweiten könnte
historischer erfolg in nordirland bei
regionalwahlen gewinnt die
nationalistische sinn fein partei
haushoch
und rückkehr aus dem all matthias maurer
ist wieder in deutschland und schildert
seinen blick auf den planeten im
krisenmodus
es ist eine traurige situation die
ukraine gedenken morgen der opfer des
zweiten weltkriegs gleichzeitig erleidet
sie hohe verluste durch den russischen
angriffskrieg wieder haben raketen die
hafenstadt odessa getroffen aus dem
stahlwerk in mariupol haben es heute
offenbar die letzten zivilisten
herausgeschafft aber die angst ist groß
dass russlands militär die attacken zum
tag des sieges über nazi deutschland
verschärft alexandra vacano
es soll eine demonstration militärischer
stärke werden die sieges parade auf dem
roten platz in moskau mit panzern
raketensystemen flugshow heute nochmal
generalprobe währenddessen neue
russische raketen angriffe am mittag auf
die süd ukrainische hafenstadt odessa es
soll ein militärflugplatz getroffen
worden seien in der ukraine wächst nun
auch die angst dass die russen das
stahlwerk in mario pohl bis montag
erobern wollen inzwischen sind wohl alle
frauen kinder und ältere aus dem
stahlwerk evakuiert worden heißt es aus
kiew und der ukrainische präsident hofft
auf die rettung der soldaten
wir arbeiten auch einen diplomatischen
optionen um unser militär zu retten dass
ich immer noch ein as of style aufhält
einflussreiche vermittler sind beteiligt
einflussreiche staaten
der bevorstehende 93 kiews bürgermeister
vitali klitschko waren in den kommenden
tagen besteht eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit von raketenbeschuss
in allen regionen der ukraine seien sie
vorsichtig und achten sie auf ihre
sicherheit
von der ostfront vermelden die ukraine
das keine russischen durchbrüche trotz
täglichen beschusses
dafür sollen die besatzer eine
abspaltung von herzen und russische
pässe für die menschen in der
südukrainischen
russland ist für immer hier daran sollte
kein zweifel bestehen es wird keine
rückkehr in die vergangenheit geben so
ein vertreter der kreml-partei es ist 73
im krieg und die ukraine schaut mit
großem bangen auf die nächsten tage
richtung moskau
gebe mir zu katrin eigendorf nach kiew
kathrin die russen feiern am neunten mal
den tag des sieges über nazi-deutschland
die ukraine gedenken am 8 mai der
kriegsopfer womit ist an beiden tagen zu
rechnen
also der tag morgen wird hier im ganz im
zeichen einer abspaltung von der
gemeinsamen erinnerungskultur stehen die
ukraine setzt damit ein zeichen und sagt
es gibt keine gemeinsame geschichte mit
russland es gibt keinen gemeinsamen
feiertag wir gedenken hier der opfer des
zweiten weltkrieges am 8 mai zusammen
mit polen zum beispiel während russland
an diesem tag den sieg über nazi
deutschland feiert was die ukraine mit
großer sorge sieht denn putin wird an
diesem tag natürlich auch den krieg
gegen die ukraine in den mittelpunkt
stellen der für ihn ja eine art
fortsetzung des sieges über nazi
deutschland ist er sieht ja auch hier
eine vermeintlich faschistische
regierung an der macht dir entmachten
will deswegen sieht man den tag hier mit
großer sorge es gibt viele warnungen
auch hier in kiel wo es bislang relativ
ruhig ist dass man hier aufpassen soll
man rechnet auch hier wieder mit
möglichen raketenangriffen live aus kiew
katrin eigendorf vielen dank wir schauen
jetzt nach hf das ja lange als
frontstaat galt zu hunderttausenden sind
die einwohner aus der stadt geflohen und
dort hat sich das blatt jetzt gewendet
die ukraine drängt die russischen
angreifer nämlich zurück und konnte
mehrere vororte zurückerobern
mittlerweile ist hf das nur 20 kilometer
von der russischen grenze entfernt liegt
zur zuflucht geworden für menschen aus
den umkämpften gebieten im osten und
ginzel und michael haselrieder berichten
wir sind in hp für besuchen eine
unterkunft für ukrainische flüchtlinge
aus den kampfgebieten aller ist zum
ersten mal wieder beim friseur zwei
monate hat sie im keller gelebt während
draußen bomben viel
wir hatten kaum etwas zu essen brot gab
es zwei monate nicht
natalia ist erst vor ein paar tagen aus
ihrem dorf direkt an der front geflohen
sie zeigt uns ein video
neben unserem haus ist eine bombe
eingeschlagen nur 10 bis 15 meter
entfernt wir waren gerade im keller da
haben wir beschlossen zu fliegen die
häuser haben gebrannt alles hat gebrannt
auch viele kinder sind den angriffen
entkommen sie malen um ihre erfahrungen
zu verarbeiten erzählen uns von
russischen soldaten
es sind sehr schlechte menschen es sind
männer die schießen
sie kommen in die häuser und nehmen die
männer mit sie schießen auf menschen
schießen mit panzern auf die häuser sie
schießen auch auf autos
ihre mütter berichten russische kämpfer
hätten junge ukrainische männer bedroht
und sie mitgenommen unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht
sie haben ihre hände und füße mit
klebeband gefesselt von vielen jungs die
sie nach russland über die grenze
gebracht haben wissen wir nicht wo sie
sind niemand weiß ob sie noch leben oder
nicht diese frauen und ihre kinder sind
weg von der front doch in sicherheit
sind sie nicht auch um car kit wird auch
gekämpft
russische menschenrechtler haben in
stuttgart den theodor heuss preis
bekommen er geht in diesem jahr an die
organisation memorial
mitbegründerin scherbakowa sagte man
könne den machthaber nur die kraft der
schwachen entgegensetzen memorial
engagiert sich unter anderem für die
aufarbeitung politischer
gewaltherrschaft und für die
überlebenden sowjetische arbeitslager in
russland ist die organisation seit
dezember verboten
im jüngsten zdf politbarometer zur
morgigen schleswig-holstein-wahl können
die cdu und ihr ministerpräsident
günther auf gute zustimmungswerte
blicken das zdf wahlstudio in kiel mit
hochrechnungen analysen und ergebnissen
geht im morgen auf sendung bettina
schausten es natürlich jetzt schon da
bettina gerade schon erwähnt anja
günther hat ein deutliches umfrage
polster was wird das spannende morgen
bei der wahl
also zunächst mal muss die cdu mit
ministerpräsident günther den sieg auch
einfahren
denn wenn die wähler meinen die sache
sei gelaufen kann der erfolg weniger
glanzvoll ausfallen als erwartet
zweitens wird es ein spannendes rennen
geben um platz zwei die grünen sind an
die spd heran gerückt die morgen mit
einem historisch schlechten ergebnis
rechnen muss nur sechs wochen nachdem
spd kantersieg im saarland ja und dann
ist da die große frage nach der neuen
regierung hier im norden jamaika steht
gut da wird aber wohl geschichte sein
wenn es für zwei partner reicht schwarz
grün ist da eine perspektive aber
überraschungen nicht ausgeschlossen
alles gründe morgen dabei zu sein vor
allem geht es um das signal aus kiel
nach düsseldorf nächsten sonntag wird in
nordrhein westfalen gewählt wo die lage
deutlich knapper aussieht also es lohnt
sich einzuschalten wir melden uns morgen
ab 17 40 aus dem wahlstudio hier an der
kieler förde bis dann vielen dank und
bis morgen bettina schausten
wir schauen jetzt auf die regionalwahlen
in großbritannien genauer in die provinz
nordirland das ergebnis das darf man
historisch nennen denn die schönfeld
partei liegt uneinholbar vorne sie galt
einst als politischer arm der einer
terror-organisation die jahrzehntelang
mit bombenanschlägen gewaltsam für eine
vereinigung nordirlands mit der republik
irland kämpfte bis 1998 dann das
karfreitagsabkommen den bürgerkrieg
beendete jetzt könnte schon fan sogar
nordirlands neue regierungschefin
stellen andreas stamm berichtet
100 jahre nordirische geschichte auf den
kopf gestellt ein jubelmeer zehn fällen
stärkste kraft im parlament zum ersten
mal siegen die die eine vereinigung mit
der republik irland wollt
ich bestärke alle die die vereinigung
noch nicht sehen lasst uns reden eine
sachliche debatte darüber führen wie
unsere zukunft aussehen soll kein
triumphgeheul denn um regierungschefin
zu werden braucht es die zustimmung der
größten unionistenpartei die op eine
besonderheit teil des friedensabkommens
von 98 doch die unionisten hatten
angekündigt lieber keine regierung ein
politisches vakuum als juniorpartner
sein für den verein weil das ihren
größten albtraum näher bringen könnte
nordirland nicht mehr britisch sondern
irischen könnte auch bei den wahlen in
irland stärkste kraft werden dass in
beiden teilen zu sein wäre ein
deutlicher schritt richtung vereinigung
aber die britische regierung wird eine
volksabstimmung darüber erst zustimmen
wenn sich eine mehrheit für die
vereinigung abzeichnet und die gibt es
noch nicht
weiterer streitpunkt nordirland
sonderstatus nachdem rexit es ist teil
des eu binnenmarkts geblieben so soll
eine grenze zu irland ein mögliches
wieder aufflammen von gewalt verhindert
werden die unionisten wollen diesen
sonderstatus abschaffen da er
wirtschaftlich den weg richtung
vereinigung befördere doch auch hier hat
der wähler gesprochen eine mehrheit im
neuen parlament ist gegen eine
grundsätzliche neuverhandlungen mit der
eu damit ist das wahlergebnis auch eine
niederlage für die britische regierung
die brüssel seit monaten mit dem bruch
des brh exit vertrags druck
in afghanistan schränken die
radikalislamischen taliban die rechte
von frauen weiter ein sie müssen in der
öffentlichkeit nun burka tragen einen
ganzkörperschleier bei dem auch die
augen bedeckt sind schon in den
vergangenen monaten hatten die taliban
weiterführende schulen für mädchen
geschlossen zehntausende frauen die für
die regierung arbeiteten verloren
außerdem ihre arbeitsplätze
in kubas hauptstadt havanna sind bei
einer explosion in einem luxushotel
mindestens 25 menschen ums leben
gekommen mindestens 64 wurden verletzt
schuld soll ein unfall beim befüllen der
gastanks des hotels gewesen sein das
gebäude stand nach einer krone bedingten
schließung schon länger leer sollte aber
in wenigen tagen wieder eröffnen zur
vorbereitung waren viele angestellte vor
ort
in der korona pandemie haben wir ja jede
menge daten preisgegeben wo wir wann im
restaurant waren ob wir uns infiziert
haben wie oft wir uns haben dixon lassen
und da hat sich eine riesige datenflut
angesammelt in behörden beim arbeitgeber
auf unseren handys zeit zum löschen
sagen datenschützer sven rieken
digitaler frühjahrsputz kann so aussehen
nass und laut sein oder so in zwei
jahren pandemie haben sich viele check
ins und aus und registrierungen
angesammelt persönliche daten die
eigentlich längst gelöscht sein müssten
müssten ich möchte gar nicht wissen was
mit den daten passiert wenn wie man
kaffee trinken ja wenn wir uns irgendwo
ein buch aus buchen also wir haben ja
das schon spuren hinterlassen ich denke
mal das wird einen großen papierkorb
rollen und der wird am ende des tages
im kamin rein und fertig ist das gibt
sicher keine meldepflicht gilt auch für
die zahlreichen papierlisten zb am
arbeitsplatz auch alle atteste in
zusammenhang mit masken pflicht
befreiung oder impf und genießen den
status dürfen nicht in der personalakte
landen ein unfreundlicher arbeitgeber
könnte die nutzen können sie in die
personalakte eintragen könnte bei
späteren beförderungen oder
zuständigkeit entscheidungen unbewusst
oder bewusst diese
gesundheitsinformationen verwenden
ohnehin ist so ein digitaler
frühjahrsputz eine gute gelegenheit
ungenutzte apps und vor allem die
accounts dahinter zu löschen weil dort
überall daten sind die natürlich auch
von den unternehmen weiter genutzt
werden können aber vielleicht auch von
cyberkriminellen und dann vielleicht zu
identitätsdiebstahl oder zu anderen
nachteilen für den bürger genutzt werden
und das ist gefährlich die daten der low
carb jedenfalls sind diese woche
komplett verschwunden kontakt nach
verfolgung gibt es nicht mehr daher
wurden 41 millionen nutzerdaten gelöscht
die app ist damit auch ein fall für den
digitalen frühjahrsputz
die internationale raumstation iss eine
insel auf der alles in ordnung war so
nennt sie der deutsche astronaut
matthias maurer der das vergangene halbe
jahr dort verbrachte heute morgen ist er
wieder in deutschland angekommen und die
welt ist eine andere als vor seinem
start im november über seine rückkehr
susanne freitag
er ist ein bisschen wackelig auf den
beinen sagt matthias maurer selbst seine
erste botschaft am boden ist dafür umso
klarer während seiner mission brach auf
der erde der ukraine krieg aus ich komme
jetzt von einer insel in der auf der
alles in ordnung ist eine insel die 22
jahre lang als symbol für internationale
kooperation freundschaft und friedliche
zusammenarbeit der menschen gestanden
hat und von dort oben aus zusehen wie
die welt and lies das ist natürlich sehr
bedrückend unter erschrecken sechs
monate lang hat er gemeinsam mit russen
und amerikanern zusammen gearbeitet und
zusammen geliebtes sind seine weltraum
brüder sagt er fast 150 experimente hat
maurer gemacht viele dienen dem klima
und umweltschutz mehrmals täglich
schwebte er zum weltraum fenster von
dort hat er gesehen wie sich der planet
verändert hat man sieht auch gletscher
in gewissen bereichen noch karten
eingezeichnet die wir jetzt nicht mehr
erkannt haben also man erkennt auf den
klimawandel von oben und das ist
natürlich alles
mit eigenen augen zu etwas zu sehen zu
spüren das ist noch mal viel viel viel
intensiver gestern frühmorgens splash
down vor der küste floridas plötzlich
wieder schwer greift natürlich gibt ein
paar annehmlichkeiten wie das essen von
einem teller wurde ich alles an
wegfliegen wächst und hebt das ist
natürlich schon schön also für gewisse
dinge ist die schwerkraft toll für
andere dinge kann man auf sie verzichten
matthias maurer der vierte deutsche der
auf der iss geforscht hat er hat ein
weiteres kapitel deutscher
raumfahrtgeschichte geschrieben
sympathischer kreation zurück zur erde
unserem sport und julie christie genau
los geht's mit tennis alexander zverev
ist nach seinem frühen aus in münchen
wieder besser in schwung und bleibt beim
masters in madrid auf kurs richtung
titelverteidigung
im viertelfinale besiegte er den
kanadier verlierer alias im in zwei
sätzen die deutsche nummer eins vorne im
bild spielt sich immer mehr aus der
formkrise vor allem im ersten satz
dominiert zwar auf den gegner 623 nach
33 minuten
mitte des zweiten durchgangs verliert
der weltranglistendritte beim stand von
4 zu 1 kurz den faden der kanadier
gleicht aus dort wäre nach seinem
trainerwechsel auch mental wieder
stärker kämpft sich durch und holt sich
mit 7 5 das ticket ins halbfinale dort
wartet kein geringerer als eine der
besten sandplatzspieler der welt der
grieche stefanos city pass
jetzt zum fußball erstmalig in der
bundesliga-geschichte am vorletzten
spieltag nicht alle partien parallel ihr
die ergebnisse heute bisher kein
heimsieg reuter führt unterliegt
dortmund 1 3 hoffenheim leverkusen 24
dämpfer für freiburg 1 zu 4 gegen union
berlin köln feier trotz des 0 2 1 gegen
wolfsburg und freut sich auf europa
gestern besiegte bochum bielefeld zwei
zu eins alles zum abendspiel härter
mainz ausführlich im sportstudio morgen
drei spiele und die meisterehrung der
bayern hinter dem spitzenduo hat nun
auch leverkusen die champions league
sicher der kampf um den vierten platz
für die königsklasse freiburg kann
morgen von leipzig überholt werden union
ist erneut für den europacup
qualifiziert ebenso köln erstmals seit
fünf jahren im keller kann nachher
hertha den klassenerhalt sichern
stuttgart geht ins saison auf dem
relegationsplatz und würde mit einem
sieg bei den bayern bielefelds abstieg
besiegeln führt plant bereits für die
zweite liga und dort kann am abend
spitzenreiter schalke mit einem erfolg
gegen st pauli die rückkehr ins oberhaus
perfekt machen der hamburger sv rückt
durch das 2 2 1 gegen hannover auf
tabellenplatz 2 dank der besseren
tordifferenz vor die punktgleichen
darmstädter und bremen wo bei werder
morgen noch vorbeiziehen kann zu gast im
aktuellen sportstudio bei katrin
müller-hohenstein tischtennisspieler
dimitrij ovtcharov der wegen des ukraine
kriegs seinen langjährigen russischen
verein fakel orenburg verlassen hat und
noch zu leichtathletik verkorkster
saison einstieg für zehnkampf
weltmeister niklas kaul beim mehrkampf
meeting in ratingen gab der 24-jährige
kurz nach dem start bis 400 meter lauf
wegen schwindel auch die vier
disziplinen davor liefen nicht wie
erhofft für die wm im sommer in den usa
ist er aber als titelverteidiger gesetzt
aber für die em in münchen im august da
muss er die norm knacken dadurch muss
sagen wir danke schön christin und wir
haben auch gute nachrichten vom wetter
morgen überwiegend sonnig und nächste
woche soll ich mir gleich von katja
horneffer das heute journal mit
christian sievers um 22 uhr 45 genießen
sie den samstagabend das gesamte heute
19 team bedankt sich fürs zuschauen und
sagt bis morgen um 19 uhr
[Musik]
guten abend damit die warmluft diese bei
uns so richtig in gang kommt braucht es
nicht nur ein hoch sondern auch ein tief
so kommt die warme luft aus
südwesteuropa zu uns schon morgen liegen
dort die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 25
und 35 grad bei uns wird es heute nach
kalt besonders im norden da sinken die
werte auf 6 bis 2 grad droht also
örtlich noch einmal bodenfrost sonst
gehen die temperaturen auf 11 bis 6 grad
zurück rest einer kleinen kaltfront
liegen heute nacht noch zwischen berlin
brandenburg und der eifel etwas regen
fällt noch am alpenrand morgen gibt es
dann für die meisten einen sehr sonnigen
tag nur den mittelgebirgen kann sich
dann am nachmittag hier und da mal ein
kleiner regenschauer oder ein gewitter
bilden am alpenrand sieht dagegen trübe
aus da gibt es häufiger noch schauer und
gewitter die temperaturen liegen morgen
meist der 14 bis 21 grad im südwesten
geht es dagegen bis auf 24 grad und am
montag gibt es dann strahlenden
sonnenschein bis zu 26 grad aber schon
am dienstag wird es dann von nordwesten
wieder wechselhafter und damit auch
wieder kälter wie sie aber hier am
temperatur und wettertrend für frankfurt
am main sehen können ist es nur eine
vorübergehende temperatur delle schuld
bis zum nächsten wochenende steigen die
werte wieder bis 25 grad schönes
wochenende